[Música]
volvemos a repasar la economía en
directo américa de france 24 jorge
seguimos entonces actualizando las
noticias económicas en torno al
conflicto en ucrania así es raúl y bueno
es que las sanciones que ya ha impuesto
occidente comienza a tener su impacto en
las finanzas locales de rusia el banco
central de rusia elevó su tipo de
interés a la cifra más alta en casi dos
décadas e impuso controles sobre el
flujo de capitales para que su economía
no se desplome el emisor ruso elevó su
tipo de interés del 95 al 20 por ciento
asimismo prohibieron a los corredores de
bolsa la venta de los valores en manos
de extranjeros otra de las medidas que
se tomó de parte del ministerio de
finanzas de rusia es la venta
obligatoria del 80 por ciento de las
divisas que presiden los residentes por
concepto de exportaciones en algunos
bancos de moscú sobre todo los afectados
por las sanciones se formaron largas
filas de ciudadanos que buscaban retirar
sus ahorros la invasión de ucrania por
parte de rusia ha provocado una enorme
fuga de capitales el ceip y global
rating rebajó el viernes la calificación
crediticia del país por debajo del grado
de inversión
y también la volpe anunció un acuerdo
político para excluir a varios bancos
rusos del sistema de pagos
interbancarios swift hacia raúl y
también anunciaron el bloqueo de toda
transacción con el banco central de
rusia esto como respuesta a la invasión
de ucrania el bloqueo de las
transacciones con el banco central ruso
será efectivo una vez que la medida se
publique en el diario oficial de la
unión europea eeuu también prohibió a
las entidades estadounidenses cualquier
operación con el banco central de rusia
además de congelar todos los activos en
dólares de esa entidad la medida que
entra en vigor de forma inmediata impide
en la entidad rusa acceder a sus
reservas en dólares en el mundo y
prohíbe a cualquier institución
financiera o empresa estadounidense
hacer algún tipo de transacciones u
operaciones con el banco central de
rusia el gobierno alemán por su parte
abogó por una desconexión parcial de
reducía el sistema de pago swift para
garantizar las transacciones
relacionadas con el abastecimiento de
materias primas y la energía que hace de
un tema clave durante este conflicto
algunos analistas estiman que la
exclusión de los bancos rusos de swift
golpeará a las reservas rusas en otras
monedas que no sean
como el dólar o la libra para hoy se
esperan ya algún tipo de respuesta de
estas medidas de parte de rus escuchemos
qué opinan los analistas al respecto la
bestia rusia ha puesto en marcha varios
mecanismos ya cuenta con unas finanzas
públicas especialmente saneadas por lo
que depende mucho menos del exterior
para financiarse hoy en día las
entidades públicas rusas pueden
financiarse simplemente en el mercado
nacional lo mismo ocurre si quieren
financiar inversiones así que no depende
mucho de las inversiones extranjeras no
es muy dependiente del sistema del dólar
porque al final gran parte del comercio
se hace en yuanes chinos o simplemente
en rublos su moneda local así que aunque
su economía puede funcionar de forma
autosuficiente esto no significa que no
vaya a haber un impacto sobre todo en el
consumo de los hogares en el clima
empresarial pero la realidad es que no
va a tener el impacto esperado por
occidente hay muchos colchones de
seguridad en rusia hoy en día para
permitir que el efecto se desvanezca con
y hay muchas más noticias en torno al
impacto económico de esta crisis así s
bueno comenzamos con el rublo que se
desplomó y el mercado forex casi un 30%
frente al dólar tras el anuncio de
algunos bancos del sistema de
comunicaciones interbancaria
internacional swift así como el bloqueo
por parte de la unión europea y ahora
eeuu de las transacciones con el banco
central de rusia este lunes la unión
europea discutirá la propuesta que hizo
estados unidos sobre liberar las
reservas de petróleo de forma coordinada
para contrarrestar la subida de los
precios aunque algunas fuentes han
manifestado que no hay acuerdos para
llegar a una decisión de este tipo y la
plataforma de hospedaje ervin bi
ofrecerá alojamiento gratuito a corto
plazo para 100.000 refugiados ucranianos
que huyen de la invasión rusa en su país
según un comunicado la empresa ofreció
su apoyo a los gobiernos de polonia
rumanía alemania y hungría para
coordinar las estadías y hasta ahora hay
más de 500.000 ucranianos que han salido
del país en la comisión europea prevé
que la cifra podría aumentar en los
próximos días jorge indicadores
iniciamos en asia las acciones japonesas
terminaron al alza ya que los inversores
esperaban un resultado positivo de las
conversaciones previstas entre rusia y
ucrania las bolsas europeas se
desplomaron por las nuevas sanciones
tras su invasión a ucrania mientras que
la subida de los precios del petróleo
alimentó el temor a una mayor inflación
para finalizar jorge que nos trae como
cifra del día la cifra del día es 100
mil millones de dólares esa es la
riqueza oculta estimada de vladimir
putin pero oficialmente el presidente
ruso declara que gana apenas 140 mil
dólares al año y que posee solamente un
pequeño apartamento jorge gracias por
toda la información económica nos vemos
mañana con más nos vamos directo hasta
parís
[Música]